you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I was I just
peripherally I could see you kind of
staring at me Ryan it's kind of weird
well we got creepy lighting in the room
right now yeah I wish you guys could see
the lighting right now okey but when we
start video in two weeks you will see it
but right now it's just like one lights
missing so delay it looks like I'm doing
a horror podcast and if you're my good
buddy from Fangoria Dallas who's that
one of the main guys pretty much the
main guy produced bone tomahawk and
you're listening cuz you always listen
to the podcast and he's been want me to
do a finger a podcast and god I'd love
to do it we got to figure that out one
day when it makes perfect sense for both
of us but you know I also want to do his
movies - god I love you
Dallas you're a genius does that mean
kissing ass Ryan a little bit well right
but Dallas likes me we have a mutual
respect and love for each other that
helps yeah I think is important did you
have a good week ma'am yeah I did yeah
yeah it's been a good week do you listen
to the podcast I do you listen to the
Nicky Whelan I did you did yeah so we
recorded it together uh-huh and then you
actually you know you didn't edit this
one Mia did she did yes cuz you're gonna
head it the videos coming up what you're
working on right now yes we're coming
out in a couple weeks right but me it
does a great job she's fantastic
he's amazing media and she's really
helped you in yeah some good pointers I
mean I already had plenty of respect
when I had even more respect you know
and I'm in the editing process of all
this she's she's right yeah cuz you got
you got a people want to listen and they
won't want to listen to a lot of us and
ooze and you know it's got to sound good
I just don't want it to sound natural
sound Matt you don't have to be choppy
edited edited T editing a dirty last
week Nicky Whelan what was a good
episode in fact my assistant Jess was
like I love this episode and she doesn't
say that often I mean I think she likes
them all but this one rang pretty true
for I don't know a lot of us I feel like
you know you see a pretty woman or a
good-looking guy and you think oh they
have it made they have this then you
realize we all have been through [ __ ]
like so and I think every every guest
sort of surprises me in their own way
and she was very forthcoming very honest
and that's great and so I was I was
really pleased with that with that we
just been very lucky with guests you
know some people might say oh well why
don't you get Steven Spielberg as what
people say or renée's that wiggler Zam
what so it's funny it's the you you
haven't gotten it right once but I'm
gonna let you keep going [ __ ] but you
know look I'd love to get whoever you
know I turned down guests I just because
I think there's certain guests that are
right for the show and if you have a
story if you want to talk about
something that I think is gonna help
people and just you're interesting I
love it but look of course you know we
always try to get big guests I mean I
know you turn people down but you did
not have to be so rude to Martin
Scorsese yeah well you crossed a line
what else is Scorsese gonna tell us that
we don't already know of course I get
Scorsese God that would be genius anyway
I want to say thanks to all the patrons
out there that my patrons were racking
them up there's 234 something patrons
now who are subscribed to the podcast
and this is a it's called patreon and
you guys get extra footage and you get
to ask questions there's a bunch of
stuff check it out I just want to say I
appreciate all you guys and all the
sweet cameos that I do those are fun
those are easy again supporting the
podcast you know you guys know what to
do alright I've said it you guys are
avid listeners but if you're new spread
the word if you like the podcast so I
could pay ryan here and the other guys
it's nice to I'll get more people
subscribed and you know it's funny I
send an email to all my friends and I
said guys can you please subscribe and
most of them hadn't subscribed these are
my friends okay you do look I subscribed
I'm like this has been going on for a
year and a half it's free it's my
friends it's like dude subscriptions and
downloads are important this is why oh
but they're doing it and my buddy Harlan
who's a comedian look at his Twitter's
like hey buddy I tweeted it and like
four people already retreat we did it
man you got four more like Thank You
Harlan but look I I love it like I said
that no one's ever gonna stop me from
doing this podcast I just want it to
blow up and help more and more people
trying to get dr. drew in the show so
working on him and some other great
people but look let's get into this
podcast by the way I'm gonna be in rich
in Virginia on the 28th 29th with Tom
doing a signing we're doing a Smallville
Nights 2 on a Saturday night improv show
and I'm also doing a staged it with
Jason Mann's on Sunday night which is I
believe the 20 maybe the 30th whatever
that month Sunday is the 28th 29 to 29th
of February we're doing stages so if you
go online to stage it we're gonna play a
live acoustic show online so you could
watch it our guest today is from Baldwin
New York I have known her for a little
while she was a big heart throbbing
heart throb dude guys just loved her
women loved her she has the voice of an
angel we get to sing a little bit on
this episode she's just and she had a
tough life man she really divulged so
much information Thank You Taylor Dayne
for [ __ ] being so cool I know people
are gonna thank you for this story so
without further ado let's get inside
Taylor Dayne it's my part of you you're
listening to inside of you
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you want the thing on there it's like a
condom yeah
protects who then you wouldn't know
about those what do you hate condoms did
you ever think that'd be your first
question that's a guess them no I hate
him
I honestly is I'm not that I'm not a guy
I can't say I'm wrapped up in but uh
yeah open one I'm wrapped up in in in
hate putting on a condom you ever see
some of them struggle so hard and I'm
like guy just you know find a way to
make it happen but no I've never really
had a whole night spent working on a
condom I've pulled one off once and said
not even happened and thrown it against
the wall but we're doing this without
one we're taking a chance please I mean
you know you're from Baldwin from
Freeport I'm from ruse you know you just
kept going and going
Roslyn where no no I grew up don't you
watch how didn't you listen to Howard
Stern he used to say that Leslie Bund
him in that that Taylor Dayne right next
door so we were the Roosevelt you know
Eddie Murphy Roosevelt Freeport and
Baldwin I don't listen to that interview
how it's done well you know yeah I gotta
listen to that why don't I do my
homework island people was he cool did
you like it
well did I like him yeah did I like Long
Island
did you like Howard Stern Howard's funny
he's he's definitely changed I mean here
we are today talking Howard [ __ ] yeah
it's just so true he's the one who
started at all he started all this kind
of not he actually I was I interviewed
Macaulay Culkin and somehow the show
went viral the some clips or whatever it
was about Michael Jackson whatever and
it went on Stern and Stern's reading the
stuff guy yeah so Macaulay Culkin was
talking to Michael Rosenbaum inside of
you with Michael Rose him up oh that's a
double entendre Rob and it's like you
know it's a play on words and I'm like
[ __ ] yeah she's like um you know we
liked him he was he's unsmooth oh we
used to watch small but you know he was
a big fan I know me and I was always
bomb I was like gosh he talks about smut
brother would call me the more dude
Stern's talking about [ __ ] I never was
on his show call you Rosie uh no he just
said you know
yeah he gave me the whole he's good I
like that guy he's good but I was always
hoping it's one cousin one for the Jew
team he's very good that way but I wish
that I was always a guy you know if I
got in Stern or Letterman
now that Letterman's gone well he's not
going cuz he's got that new shell right
Ryan yeah what's that called
it's the asking Ryan the - Letterman's
coming back is and hopefully with a
shave yeah I don't care I love David
David was always kind to me a beautiful
guy what year were you on on Letterman
it's called my next guest sorry my oh my
god definitely in the 90s 93 definitely
cuz I remember doing I'll wait on there
did he flirt with you yes he likes you
didn't he yeah how'd you know I could
just tell I was like hi did he call you
afterwards and he oh wow I don't thinks
no not David no no you let that go he
let that sleep did you ever sleep with a
Late Show host
or how about a afternoon show scene one
naked that's that as far as it goes
though wait
naked who'd you see naked um what's that
one guy um I think you all know him
we're gonna leave it at that
not naked like naked Lake and afraid but
naked and like I saw him like he was
definitely working the room is this
somewhere near now uh on and off Fallon
no first of all I've party with Jimmy
Jimmy I adore you I party well I love
Jimmy come to a house party let's let's
borrow a party will he come
falen of course I'll come I don't know
Jimmy Fallon I know Kimmel and Kimmel
stays great it was wonderful
well I like Jimmy fell I party with him
at the Derby how come you've never come
to the Derby with me and I went to that
I went to the Derby one time who took
who'd you know I went with some friends
some old some friends from college and
then oh but you went like you went like
you know no no but name-dropping here
brookheimer invited me to his party in
his house in kentucky afterwards because
i play hockey with him name-drop
name-drop yeah I went to his house it
was like he was ending his post like
Derby party and was like Sigourney
Weaver oh you you can't imagine the
eclectic mix yeah who's the biggest star
you've met that you're
like all right I'm star starting could
you met everybody
not every imeem you were the bit you
were the biggest at one time like you
were the biggest like one of the biggest
things there people wanted that's the
thing when you're hot people just want
you right well I mean who haven't I mean
okay so Michael Jackson Prince right
those are the Prince definitely threw me
off my game because there was a lot to
it
what do you mean there's a lot to it now
that you can't you can see I'm not gonna
talk about that what whatever but I have
to say with Prince it's just he was a
funny freakin guy he was just funny he
was good at everything so when he came
up and just would flirt and talk and
then he's like you're gonna do this
you're gonna do that I'm like am I am I
gonna do this am I gonna do that he goes
yeah you coming to mini app you're gonna
meet me at my house you're gonna do this
and I'll be like okay like what do you
say you did yeah how old were you you
know I don't know 25 so you say yeah I'm
gonna press well I said to my manager I
go dude we're going Mike Prince is like
that he's throwing this parties doing
this we're singing after you know we're
in Frankfort now we're in in Minneapolis
what's the difference are you are you
fearless
you seem fearless you seem like all you
guys say that no no you do though
because I'm not as I can seem fearless
at times but for someone to just be like
you know when we when you came in here I
was like you know I would you sing she
does I say I don't need anything I don't
need a guitar I don't need nothing you
you don't need a guitar like there's
this confidence that you've had that
you're so I mean because your voice is
so good but like some of these people
for instance Rage Against the Machine
they're coming back right and I'm like
how are they coming back I love them but
his voice was like 30 years ago
how is his voice good how could it
possibly be good but you but that's not
what they're about is it is that the
voice is that the sound the texture tone
yes me you expect a standard of
excellence when it comes to vocal sounds
I can't think the guy age Against the
Machine or Henry Rollins or any of that
matter you're really worried about his
sound I mean he's I don't want to sound
good I just saw a rat Stephen Pearcy oh
mercy one of the best voices I thought
like in heaven yeah yeah you're a good
you're a good one Rosie why is that I
just think that's cool you know all your
bank well
just saw him and I was just like you
know I've seen him before and he's got
just this great voice but he's in his
sixties now and it's hard to hit those
it's hard do you have like an athlete
look you're I am right you're not old
but you train I train my voice how do
you do it what do you do well I
certainly I people don't know this about
me but I'm a pratically trained I
studied up radically to actually have a
voice and maintain it and sustain it
over a course of a period of time
knowing I would have a career and my
maestro my my actual teacher would come
to the clubs and go oh oh
Leslie Leslie Wonder Leslie yeah he goes
licks lists you're gonna have the
foundation for you know having longevity
and that's was the key for me and I
always knew I wanted be a rock and roll
star whatever you want to call it the
day I never thought I'd be a pop star
dance tour whatever you want to call
whatever this is and music top 18 and
their list of dance top well here it is
female artist of all time 35 I guess it
has to do with on you sold 70 million
albums yeah 75 s man that's a lot of
albums
I think our band has sold a hundred and
sixty CDs in the last three weeks left
good I feel like that every show I might
sell a hundred CDs so don't worry about
it the world has changed we're all good
we're still here baby it's fun isn't it
can you still have a good time do you
still wear yeah when I'm on stage and
when you're in doing stuff like this
when you're when you have the
opportunity to reflect a little bit
think back about it yeah writing I wrote
a memoir at the last two three years I
did TED talk there's a reason you know
because people do want to see what it
takes to maintain and sustain something
have a voice they'll have something to
say so yeah I have a good time
and I have a frustrating time at well
what all right that's what I want to get
into because oh yeah well look you go to
concerts and your sing like of course
you we met at echoes of Hope which is a
wonderful charity that's nice your good
friend station Luc Robitaille I'm on the
board I think I don't know if you're on
the board but you're always there you're
always participant I can support them
anytime foster you go to echoes a hope
please Russ and Andie McDowell's there
and I get to introduce her know you like
Dan know like you know yes he did I like
you he's like
Taylor wants you to introduce her right
yeah great yeah so like a live from
Baldwin New York she's a girl on the
rise how do you differentiate how do you
separate like whether there's 30,000
people in Arena or there's like two it's
it's a hundred people for a charity
event do you still give it your all
yeah I think you noticed that I do but
how do you do that okay I don't know
what the thing is with me but I'll
remember this there was an article
written about me and like I don't know
The Times or some crap when I just sorta
broke but it was like six months eight
months a year into Fame and a year into
having successful singles and I did a
thing at the bidam the bitter end the
bottom line in New York City and I just
come off the Michael Jackson to her so
you're talking 60,000 people to a room
of you know we're Clive Dave all the
people oh my my record reps all the the
you know every every critic in the town
you know page six you name it was there
and they were like she tore through this
like like she was playing for 60,000
people so again I don't think I'd do
that anymore I think I can read a room a
little better but I mean I was up there
like I was feeding it to the last person
down their throat the last person in the
last seed in them in the last honesty
that's what happened me because it was I
fan of yours sure I mean everybody was
the fans I knew your music I knew some
songs but then when I heard you that
night that you were playing I was like
okay he starts singing these songs this
is honest to god Ryan it was like you
could have turned on the radio back in
89 and gone she sounds the same and
energy and the songs oh my god I love
that song that's her that's wait she
sings that I didn't know she sings that
because everybody loves tell it to my
heart and all [ __ ] yeah do you hate that
song no hell no you see your hat inside
of you I got one that says tell it to my
heart
BAM you don't give a [ __ ] you love it
you don't it's like I embrace that hell
yeah what a great title for son great
did you write that song hope I did not
do you wish you had well who the hell
wouldn't know it's great do you write
your own songs any yeah of course what's
the biggest one you've written that you
um well I wrote a song Tina Turner
recorded made at number one
whatever you want I'll wait it's not
send me a lover born to sing good songs
what about like working with Diane
Warren well you don't really work with
her she just talked orient say Diane I
see Diane once a week if not once a
month she's out there you talk about a
tenacious d how many songs ing written
it doesn't matter she still she just
puts she's too showed me in the studio
because do you see this list and I go
yeah and she had a bird on her shoulder
I'm like I'm not gonna get too close to
you Diane no matter what it is that
birds vicious-looking it's coming after
people she always had a parrot on her
shoulder you don't know this is another
story oh I mean she's just like a rusty
she was like a pirate she is anyway
she's just tenacious d so I remember in
the studio she goes you see this list
this is the top 20 she goes I have this
in front of me every week so I know what
the [ __ ] I have to compete with that's
Diane bill well I can't say still but
you go into her studio she had this
thing where don't touch it don't dust it
it had the magic juju everything was
like don't touch don't this that was it
real songs now they have a beautiful
building on not too far from the old one
right up there on I mean like you see
her once a month these you know how old
oh I guess I would think we were around
the same age if not at once you Diane
Warren's older than you she probably
might be yes yes but she's got the same
haircut it's like watching Liza Minnelli
or or Rod Stewart she looks the same she
looks great she's in therapy she'll tell
you seven days a week it's all good
did you have a happy childhood because
it tough question it's not you know I
can talk about dysfunctional day but my
listeners they know my dysfunction so
they don't want to hear me they want to
know about you because you know helps
them
okay navigate through their lives and
deal with their [ __ ] because you
obviously had so much success what so if
you had dysfunction what was it was it
your mother I sense it's your mother
well let's to break it down there Rosie
break it down well it doesn't happen
alone no my father was quite a
rageaholic my father was very my father
was an angry I have parents that are
first generation children of Holocaust
surviving parents so you know these are
families that were broken apart they
come to a country at 15 16 they get on a
boat
my father's father they come there and
then they have arranged marriages my
mother's mother came at 15 from Poland
lost all her family so these are not
happy I mean we live in some bubble when
we think about it how we've our
grandparents when we know what we know
of them you know had much suffering so
your previous your preface saying this
like you're right now what you're doing
now myself we're protecting our parents
right now are they gonna listen to this
probably right well that makes me I
wrote the book already so and I have my
father I just had a like each you know
hey you know what now we're talking wait
what am i we talked it was really brutal
was it physical abuse yeah well and it
was not to me no I was the girl I was a
special one so you didn't get hit I got
hit once or twice and that's all I
needed
but verbal abuse emotional abuse
when you say verbal it's like you suck
your piece of [ __ ] yeah you're worthless
you don't know what we was suffering is
you don't know you're an ungrateful
you're go around the house like a flame
it was like a torch like a blowtorch my
father was didn't had no there's no
desertion
he didn't desert discern between
anything and mostly he went after my mom
and he went after my older brother and
but it didn't matter every door flung
open so it was like a drunken rage like
it didn't matter and it was usually 3:00
4:00 or 5:00 in the morning it didn't
matter so PTSD ha I saw a piece
yesterday I don't see how you can on a
cellular level I mean since the time I
could remember I was watching doors open
and that caused me to have massive
issues internally by four or five I had
I was hospitalized for bladder and
kidney infections and bleeding in my yes
Amal I'm stress and just oh I held
everything in sure I held it all I'm
getting anxiety right now still or just
watching me do listen another story Ryan
I mean if it lives inside of me it's
part of the urgency I have it's part of
that also passion you see because I had
one thing one thing only and I said this
thing's gonna [ __ ] get me out of here
and that was my voice since five years
old four years old that was the deal
well tell me this did your father was
were they you know like supportive were
they like
they're Jews from Long Island from
actually from New York yes my parents
were incredibly silly even though he was
drunk even though he was never drank but
he was abusive verbally and physically
and all these things he still managed to
say hey you're really good
do you understand Sundays in the
Wonderman household worse like family
day my parents were avid theatre goers
my mother had a beautiful voice gave it
up obviously when they got married and
wasn't really you know for them the Arts
was an expression and it was a way to
get out of the [ __ ] of their lives
and it was theater they would block they
were members of the PAP the mom la mama
right it was incredible I would see that
most off-off-off Broadway stuff and it
really framed my childhood Sunday if my
father woke up on a decent side of the
bed you know there was three of us and I
had only brothers growing up I had two
brothers
it kind of makes sense now middle child
mm-hmm so I've always played with the
boys like understood like mentally like
that's and very comfortable I love my
girlfriends but like I'm just saying
like that's where it was I found no
protection there no solitude your
brothers didn't protect you at all
no did anybody protect them did anybody
stand up to your father at all one time
any now no it was all fear in that house
unfortunately my mom played the victim
role really well so my anger more went
towards her as a child I saw my father
is more you know is the stronger of the
two
so I went in that direction I held onto
that as something that nobody ever heard
me know will ever get inside nobody'll
ever so I think that's the ferocity
you know the ferociousness in some level
that you see but at the end it's such a
price to pay because you you you cut it
off like I remember sitting outside on I
grew up in apartments so I remember
sitting outside on the wall we used to
call it the wall and I was like that
[ __ ] that's going on in that house right
now nobody's ever going to do that to me
ever ever and I mean I've lived by it I
raised two children by myself I hired a
surrogate I've done it as immaculately
and as controlling as you can and I
don't mean that to say there's no
vulnerability there's no I mean my kids
are incredible
and I wouldn't change a thing quite
frankly other than I have to look at my
life and go wow I have really by design
kept it so I don't know what would you
controlled there's that word sure
I mean you you're constrained to have
somewhat some kind of control on safety
anything yes t I just to get panic
attacks like crazy you talk about
anxiety so it started with massive
bladder kidney and it all starts in the
gut that's what I hear that was four or
five years old I'm bleeding I'm you know
I'm hospitalized and we do massive
surgery all this this invasive stuff but
on a five and four and five-year-old
girl it was traumatic I've had to go
back many times through many different
therapies and modalities and try to
visit that girl my look that little girl
and tried to heal her hell hold her and
I feel like I'm in a best place now with
her just to let her you know know that
she's beautiful and loved you know in
those days I was in the hospital in the
late 60s early 70s parents don't sleep
with the children they don't get to stay
in the hospital ward I don't get nervous
when I go in to terminally ill
children's wards and things like that I
know exactly what they need they need
they need to be hugged they need to be
slept but they need to be held and they
need people around them they don't want
it there's no there's no pity there
there's no party going on it's just like
let's be friends let's hang out let's
have so I get it all right you're gonna
make me cry no start talking about the
kids and stuff - that's it yeah but
they're beautiful how about I go to the
you know the wrong I don't go there and
feel like I can't do this I go there and
I feel like a warrior like I've been
exactly where you were I made it through
you know what they need you know I know
what they need they need not to be
looked at like that you just want to get
escaped they wanna they want hugs they
want love they want affection they want
to play they want to be in the world
dude you know what it's like to be
locked up in a hospital I do and not
being able to look out you look out that
little window I used to look at that
little Kodak Cube and look at my
brothers I mean that stuff was rough and
there wasn't anybody there like you know
I became the prankster I became the
comedian ripe so the nurses
spend more time with me do you think you
did a lot of this because I know I did
whatever I did whatever it took to make
my father laugh to make him smile to
make him whatever and I knew that the
only way I was really accepted as a kid
is to crack jokes to be funny to do this
too then I did a play and like oh you're
this guy's [ __ ] so not being me was
always the thing so even to this day
it's like hey I gotta make someone so
laughs I've got to entertain I've got to
do this so there's a sense of like this
is what's gonna make him happy I have to
make him happy you know I've talked to a
lot of people about this it's just like
Annie McDowell was on here and she
talked about working with Bill Murray
and I think she's probably like a father
figure to her in a way but she just came
to work every day how do I make Bill
laugh how do I make Bill happy how do I
so you start doing things for other
people so do you think you were like oh
I want to be successful so they love me
so they you that wasn't the case
not that way no I I basically put a hand
up a wall and I just said I'll never be
in that position to force anybody love
me they're gonna see it because I'm
gonna bring my best a game right they're
gonna know how much I want this how
badly I wanted that's why you feel that
I I want that so badly when I'm onstage
it became very evident to me that
laughter and being that little girl that
was at least funny was going to get me
attention from somebody now is it with
the voice is it with for you as a comedy
whatever it was you'd get attention and
a positive and what that does to me is a
seed it's a seed of your your abilities
right so we you took something that was
a fragment of what you were actually
good at and you formed it you you know
you 10,000 our debt you just blew it up
and and that's really what I believe you
know is the foundation everybody has
something everybody everybody's born
with that gift that that that seed of
some sort of and for me it was my voice
I heard it I had a natural ear and
anyway what you felt that you loved it
you knew you had something different you
said I've got to just go with well I got
attention for it just like you did if
you got a smile from your father that's
attention and from attention from from
somebody saying wow you're good I got
that from a music teacher in school when
I was in kindergarten next thing you
know I had a solo right I'm the only
kindergartener with a solo with the
third grade with the glee club so it
just forms from there but you know
from there that's the only place where
you're feeling good right it's a high
it's it's that place except it was a
thank God and natural and something that
was at least a healthy diversion if you
will but in my mind I was like well you
hear that radio you hear this little
thing my father gave me that little
transistor a turbo you hear that voice
who's that holy [ __ ] that's Stevie
Wonder how his life looks really happy
he looks happy and not only that he's
getting paid you know what I mean and
he's got a lot of girlfriends and why do
you think you did it and he's blind well
that was his problem not the exact
everybody's problem like look right I
mean I heard we beat the Frank I heard a
lot of people on that you know Marvin
Gaye everybody has something
there's always something you're fighting
against inside of you is supported by
better help online counseling now you
know I love this kind of stuff if you're
listening you've listened to a lot of
episodes if you're an avid listener Ryan
we talk about things like this we talk
about with a lot of guests the anxiety
I'm always curious because it helps me I
talk to people you have he did with
depression how do you deal what do you
do because you always want the answers
but like the answer is it's different
for everybody
right everybody has different things
could different reasons for anxiety
whether you know you're doing with grief
or relationships and you know I've been
I've been through all about you I don't
sleep well or I didn't sleep well I'm
sleeping better now but you know life is
stressful it's hard we we could all use
help when we're feeling down but we
never know how or where to ask for it
and sometimes you feel embarrassed by it
which I'm hoping the more of this
podcast gets around people are more open
but better help better help online
counseling is available for you it's
available for all of us better help
offers licensed counselors who
specialized in issues including
depression and anxiety and many other
things you can connect privately with a
counselor through text chat phone and
video calls and I think that's pretty
cool because you know some people are
more private than I am Ryan
some people don't talk so openly and
freely as me I'm pretty open and I
always feel like oh my god if my parents
listeners my weight my mom would be like
she'd get it cuz she's a mess but know
what though
what is this
you what are you talking about you look
yeah I just don't you but you know if
you want to be private about it you can
better help offers that get help on your
own time at your own pace at an
affordable rate inside of you listeners
guys you'll get 10% off your first month
with a discount code inside better
help.com slash inside why not get help
better help calm slash inside inside of
you is brought to you by sun basket stop
eating crappy folks this is part of it
man i always talk about this stuff it's
all part of change in the routine change
in the structure changing things that
you you don't like about yourself or
that you want to get better at well you
know what i I don't we all eat like crap
sometimes but it's so easy to change
your lifestyle a little bit even if you
don't want to change it that much Sun
basket ok Sun basket caters to your kind
of healthy delicious recipes for all
kinds of dietary preferences a paleo
gluten-free Mediterranean I like
Mediterranean a lot vegetarian look it's
easy and convenient
everything is pre-portioned and ready to
prep and cook you get it you can enjoy a
full dinner of organic produce and clean
ingredients in as little as 15 minutes
no matter how much experience you have
in the kitchen and I don't have any
right and I can't Kirk worth the crap I
just can't man are you a good cook i I
do ok I don't get it I don't get a lot
of opportunity to see so I should
probably do something like this well why
not because you know you got this so
many like each week some basket gives 14
recipes to choose from they got all
these mouth-watering dishes look at a
salmon burgers with lemon dill mayo
gingered steak stir-fry with broccoli
Mediterranean garlic shrimp and Spanish
rice you can cook all this yourselves
I'm telling you it's so easy the way
they do it you know when they say you
are what you eat Ryan it's not intended
to be a joke and no one's laughing after
the 2:00 a.m. convenience store burrito
right now son Basque is offering $35 off
your order when you go right now to son
basket dot-com slash inside
enter promo code inside a checkout at
Sun basket calm / inside an enter promo
code inside at checkout for $35 off your
order Sun basket calm / inside and enter
promo code inside did your father ever
break down and descry to you and say all
the time even today my father came into
the room after those explosives moments
in my room right after he exploded
hell no three hours later when I'm
talking about things that have know when
you're on eggshells and when you're in a
PT you know a traumatic you're there's
no certainties there was no certainties
when my father came back how many times
the door would slam and he'd leave and
when you come back so I was constantly
in hyper vigilance of listening I always
was listening I was listening when he
came home to get myself ready prepared
for war all the time and then he would
come in and keep stand at the door
you're my favorite child you're my the
love of my life you're so special you're
this deep well if you talk to a
therapist now sure at the time it made
me feel secure that I knew I was really
ultimately loved but you know what in
relationships it made me have to watch
somebody crawl through fire to love me I
think on some level I mean that had to
[ __ ] up your relationships I'm sure I
mean I look at you now and I look at me
and we're both single yeah
and I wonder if you know Singh
dysfunction so much dysfunction as a kid
made us just go ah I don't know I don't
I can guarantee it but what is it what
is it that you like what do you want to
be with somebody like have you been
massively and let me imagine in love
with someone where you're just like [ __ ]
this is it yeah I have you have yeah and
you felt safe and it wasn't
dysfunctional till I didn't feel safe
and what didn't make you feel safe um
well lack of commitment moving it to the
next something that wasn't moving it
although my best relationships when you
think about him although I wasn't
invested in it because I was completely
invested in Fame and
moving my career all through my tour I
mean that was my investment I married
this and I all I and I know it wasn't
for women like oh you can get pregnant
and have a career we weren't kardi being
it back then it was like you don't talk
about who you [ __ ] you don't get
pregnant and you stay on the road I'm
sorry that's how it was and like usually
it's your boyfriend that's you know what
boyfriend was running my show
I wasn't Patti Benatar I wasn't Debbie
Harry they weren't the bleed guitar
player I wasn't you know I was like his
Pat Benatar was married to her you know
who really is fought who did it
Madonna on her terms on her you know did
it her way you know Mariah went right in
had Tommy Mottola like fighting the
fight for her I mean this is not a
simple thing in my case I guess I didn't
want anybody fighting the fight I mean
were you dealing with guys are like oh
you know any time for me you're alone
like it didn't matter I was like this is
my career I don't give a shot in my 20's
like not like that
I just didn't look at things not until I
was 29 was the first relationship where
I could say that I was actually the
clearest and and fame had already been
in the fame game five years and that
first relationship and it was very
impactful and it set me I asked right
into therapy and you know what for the
betterment it was incredible and couples
and everything and at the end of the
game I did my best and he couldn't move
in the needle forward are you better
alone do you feel are you just happier
alone sometimes I really am isn't that
funny how sometimes it's I mean I'm not
gonna say sometimes like I think about
this a lot are you thinking about this a
lot in your life like I do think about
it I love I mean I love my life but I do
recognize that I'm getting older and
that there's also this part of me that I
do love having a part I'll do love
sharing things with somebody of course
Rosie let's just hook up I guess what
are we waiting for let's use a rubber
no he throws in a relationship always I
mean Ryan 10 he's 29 30 relationships
then I mean you have ever had
relationships with younger guys now
yeah usually like a ten-year spot ten
year but what about older guys and my
age and and and because younger guys
which is I was kind of like yeah not
much you always like older guys
no I don't I'm not even your younger uh
you seem like the kind of person that
would date like a thirty year old if
you're 20 but when I was 25 how many 30
year olds were dating me no no it was
age it was just you know either
I'd never dated musicians I didn't want
to I really didn't
were you promiscuous were you like
somebody who was just going out and
saying [ __ ] it I'm gonna go play I'm
gonna rock and ramen a party at night
I'm gonna f yeah ish I did I don't know
promiscuous it's a word I know I get it
though like I mean to bodybuilders
walking my bus am I gonna get loud
but if to Playboy chicks walked in your
bus you'd be like oh and AH to you guys
coming my bus I'd be like this is the
silliest [ __ ] I ever saw I didn't take
men serious that way if they were
hunting me down usually a businessman or
stuff like that but I mean in my 20s it
would game what was game on 30s still
game on but I fell in love at 29 super
like on another level and he was a
massive he was a chef he was very well
renowned he was a world-renowned and
there was a lot of things to it and was
complicated but at the same time I found
I figured out what love was was it
heartbreaking when it ended it ended
multiple times so certain ones were
heartbreaking and then at the end I
pulled the trigger is it do you fear the
like I pictured that little girl who's
just feeling like I just I don't feel
safe you know when's my father gonna
come in when he's gonna leave what's
gonna happen it's unpredictable I don't
feel safe I don't feel safe is that sort
of a relationship ships or like you're
just like I don't trust I don't trust
you have to prove your trust you have to
prove it I still don't trust you you're
gonna [ __ ] me here it comes
or when's it coming I'm not gonna say no
I'm not gonna say no at all - all of
that is there's its cellular babe it
lives in your body
it showed that to me at four years old
it lived in my body all that rage had to
go somewhere I didn't act out my brother
my older brother acted out my older
brother from the rage was he's three or
four years older than me he was the one
that was bullied every day after school
he they put a ring of kids around him
and beat the [ __ ] out of him
and I said that's never gonna be me I
made rules with myself that's never
gonna be that's not gonna be that's me
and I really held on to them like
hardcore what did your brother do I mean
now this know did he got beat up did he
ever turn it around like and fight back
did he ever
he just wasn't he had no like to me I
was like dude why are you always like
why are they coming after you it's like
he just didn't know how to socially get
out of [ __ ] like you socially know how
to get out of things you knew you said
you knew how to work a room I would I
would get hurt I would get the [ __ ] beat
out of me because um I was really small
and weak I was the smallest kid in my
high school and I remember so you were
bullied oh yeah I was bullied for sure I
mean yeah I mean I could tell you times
but when did you turn it on so with what
it was with it was with the joking it
was with the comedy it was with the the
people just like you know I had friends
that just liked being around me but when
did chicks start digging college I
started to grow knowledge and then guys
like Kyle Finn like the big guys that
live next door and hey Dom they
protected you there was this also this
one guy Thomas Gaddis he was this Greek
guy but him and this guy woody they all
thought I was so funny they were big
football players they just protected me
I remember Thomas Gattis this is a
non-sequitur but it made me laugh
because it was the date we was at those
guys that were there genes backwards
criss cross those guys yeah what was
that song criss cross job yeah sure I
remember Thomas Gattis
he hung out with a bunch of like black
football players I think so he started
to try and act black I guess in a way
yes we I loved him but he was just was
like he was kind of a little bit of a
you know it was like yeah what's up
ladies what's it like it was a little
bit like that that was just his style
and he was cool he was good-looking and
he was like he was stuck should we talk
Western Kentucky University didn't need
a big JCC yeah okay yeah what'd you
think was gonna happen
but I loved him but I remember one time
he's when you grow up in Indiana but
hang on but I listen I remember this
this moment in college where
guys walking down the hallway this dude
any other girl this girl she's drunk at
2:00 in the morning down the football
dorms right and she's young
Thomas God has changed his name instead
of Thomas he took the th o mas and
change it to the mall
Thomas Gaddis became thumb all Gatos I
got though this girl would go down the
hallway on drunk the mom the mom the
mall and this big black dude comes and
goes the malls closed [ __ ] now go to
sleep
the malls closed from all my buddies
listen I loved it but anyway these guys
protected me because I was goofy I
thought I did tons of impressions nobody
had heard impressions I was Western
Kentucky used to give me money at
parties put dollar bills and anything
I'd make fifteen twenty bucks doing like
umm Dice Clay or doing fire marshal bill
or doing Rodney Dangerfield and that's
how I got out of beatings I think but
sometimes my mouth would get the best of
me where somebody would say something I
oh that's pretty funny was that
originally dad write that sarcasm and I
would get smacked or because I like wow
this guy's making me feel like [ __ ] I
feel intimidated [ __ ] him I'm gonna make
this big [ __ ] hurt because everybody's
gonna make fun of him now and I'd say
something really funny and as he'd go
what the [ __ ] a nobody laugh at him and
he'd [ __ ] get a job so that's that
well I had the opposite like I always
said that's never gonna happen to me I
said that at five i sat on the wall I
told you at six and then I put myself in
the circle where they I had protection
so I hung out with all the kids that
people didn't expect me to hang out with
I did all that but I had a treaty with
myself you're not gonna get [ __ ] up
you're not gonna do this you're not
going to do that Taylor you're just
gonna like Leslie whatever you want to
call Leslie joy Wonderman and that's the
real moon I think you've seen enough of
the men in my life I always went with
the you know somebody I felt protected
with safe within something of that
nature and that would get me on an
intrinsically on a on a bigger scale
because I did I definitely am NOT
anybody's arm candy quite the opposite
and I always felt like I need to feel
like they have my back do you ever see
any of your parents come out and you
like that
temper that darkness yes that [ __ ] you
and then go oh my god I and then you
should have that feeling that numbing of
like oh my god of my father I'm a mom
all by myself
yeah I see it of course I have a son
who's 17 we're at the wall I have twin
since 17 I'm at the wall but they are
the coolest kids ever and yet I know I
mean it's tough I walked out on a
relationship the one want the one I
thought it was after seven we met right
when before the kids and after and I
just remember something I'm not gonna
let you show my son what being unloving
is not gonna let you I'm not gonna let
this kid turn on me and he tries all the
time my kid yeah Levi he's a tough
mother Freaker he's a big kid he's
football football
does he know from all ya tylenol and
murine to what is it is he drink is he
trouble nope so what is it it's his
mouth people are a third party into our
relationship in the house
what do you mean a third party a
girlfriend mal like tough his
girlfriend's tough well it's not his
girlfriend anymore please dear God but
yeah he just needed some somebody
started fighting his battles between you
know he has a twin sister
it was just not snot so wait a minute
she was fighting his battle she was
mouthing off to you yeah so she was
saying [ __ ] like what do you know just
cuz you had dis
oh she didn't have the balls to say it
to my face but it was going it was
things were going around so oh I'm not
do you raise your voice course there's a
Baldwin Freeport come out oh yeah when
when I mean it like I've told as an
athlete I'm sprinter give me an example
like if I pissed you off and you just
lost it for a second you one of those
people that are just like give me a
little bit something like if I was like
I'm not [ __ ] doing that don't tell me
what to do really
yeah all right audience don't judge but
we all got this [ __ ] I will rip
your goddamn [ __ ] eyes out how do you
like that just like that but you know
what higher but yeah I think that's
mom's mom's dude that's what I think of
course
my dad used to say I hope I will beat
you to a pulp a pulp
yeah that's what my dad said one more
goddamn word out of you I will beat you
to a pulp
yeah I agree but I mean coming out of my
mouth it doesn't sound the same I think
it's cute
Ryan yeah yeah I mean it he knows she's
that she's not gonna actually rip the
child says she goes he knows at the end
of the day you're not gonna do it like
I'm like this is bang bang bang dude I
took your car away I took your phone I
took everything what about guys with the
girl weather with your daughter
oh she my daughter hits home runs what
do you expect this is how I came what do
you mean hit small boy okay so nobody
bullied me let's start right nobody I
hung out with the cool I I made sure I
had a plan since five that I wasn't
gonna get my as I watched my brother who
was in sixth grade when I'm in in for
second grade get his ass kicked out that
by all the hot whatever football players
I go no one's going to touch me I'm
gonna always be the cool chick in the
cool crowd and just make sure I skinny
buy all this no arrests no priors no
nothing just make sure you stay on your
game t dizzle and that's what I did
so all those tough mother free-cos and
all the this and all that other that
they were having my back do you really
think like when your parents say that
your parents are alive yeah
do they still they still obviously say
they love you do you roll your eyes when
they say I love you now do you believe
him babe not over the last ten years no
in the last ten years everything seems
to have come together for me forgiveness
forgiveness is the nut when you say
forgiveness is the most important
grateful and forgiveness those are
probably the two biggest words there are
I think forgiveness is something you
work on with yourself first and as you
do it with partners as you find these
these people in your life that you have
these these relationships with over time
of course it starts with our family it
starts with our brothers it starts with
our mother and father of course it does
so as you work it out and you come back
to this nucleus of being a parent or
whatever in my case 18 years ago I've
spent a lot of time working it out but
you recommend anything I've done Hoffman
the Hoffman process that's word-of-mouth
what's that oh it's we'll talk about
that what about EMDR yeah I did have I
did a little I that that that really
helped me boy you know holy [ __ ]
I was like this isn't gonna help me in
fact my therapist was like if you guys
don't know EMDR it's for post-traumatic
stress disorder and I I didn't think I
had it I was like no no no this is for
really like that's who people are having
it's called it's EMDR right it's tapping
it's a yes it's a behavior modification
tool and I I wasn't all tapping either
for this yeah you can do your yeah you
could do your own but it was like I
braaap it I movement mm-hmm the rapid I
moved yeah and I just felt like the
first time I met with this woman and it
was amazing she well she was like yeah I
go what about the a.m. deals yeah yeah
we're not gonna do that
okay and I was thinking I'm not right
for this I'm not good enough for me dr i
haven't suffered enough and that's one
of the major issues i think with people
in general and they have problems they
start to compare their problems with
other people's problems meaning that
they go oh my problem isn't as big as
that so i should just shut up or I
shouldn't do anything about it and that
is the wrong way to go cuz your problems
are affecting you and you've got to take
you've got a you've got to work on them
you've got a and for me I didn't think
EMDR was right for me I didn't think I
had PTSD well how high was your anxiety
pretty good I had pretty good anxiety in
fact you have panic attacks oh yeah oh I
had them when I was acting like what's
funny is I thought my I thought the
anxiety was just part of me I thought
the anxiety wasn't anxiety idea but I
thought it was just an energy that I
didn't like but it was just part of me
and then I realized how unhealthy it was
and how I was in fight-or-flight all the
time and how I was unhappy and you know
I started noticing at my work and I I'd
have anxiety attacks I wouldn't be
sleeping well I wasn't eating I changed
my whole life I've talked to this having
talked about in a while but I went to
this well in this facility and I I [ __ ]
I for the first time I life I had
routine I had structure I got on a
better nutritional program I I was
taking EMDR the post the in by the way
when I did take that finally the third
time she
she tapped into something I was talking
about something that happened in my life
guys I think you're ready
I got what she is I think you're ready
you want to do this I go want to do what
and I got scared because that part of me
that oh I want to please sir I want to
make sure I do this right I'm like what
the [ __ ] are you doing
you're in therapy this is for you I
still couldn't so she got me into this
moment or I stated this because I wanted
to stay there close your eyes close your
eyes when you open them I want you to
watch my finger go back and forth yeah
and I want you to stay with it stay with
that moment and I'm telling you within
30 seconds of opening my eyes I was Ball
State University I was [ __ ] it was
the ugliest cry you've ever seen it was
like I couldn't control it and boy did
it feel good man I tell my friends
sometimes I'm like you know what you
need we have these emotions in us that
just like we're too tough we'll just say
Oh like you said what they're fine then
they get bottled up more and more and
the more and more they get bottled up
what happens your gut you're all these
things start to happen right these
manifestations that come out in
different ways and with tics and things
that you do and discomfort and pain
usually it comes down to the decisions
you can live with it for so long and
then of course you know it'll eat you up
physically I mean for me I had a very
young age you know you talked this is
the thing about panic attacks and
phobias and I was clinically diagnosed
agoraphobic by 15 that's a fear of open
places correct so and I never really
spoke about it but my biggest fear was
that I couldn't be a star if I couldn't
get anywhere so what you do is you do
create safe places right and imagine if
you're well because I went to France my
parents forced me to go on this bike
trip in the middle of nowhere I got
sexually molested on it drank every
night all these things happen right I
said here I started with my parents
forced me it was a youth hostels trip it
was supposed to be a trip of a lifetime
and I'm like you have no idea it was
Lord of the Flies but it was all part of
everything before that bulimia right a
girl trying to control all the things
you hear everybody every child that
you've ever known and for you all you're
trying to do is control the environment
around you you don't want to get beaten
up you want to be liked right you want
to come out with decent grades you have
no idea what the future holds especially
when we were going to college other than
I had a game plan same look good people
on the radio we're like my idols and I
knew they had a better life than I could
ever have sitting where I was sitting in
Baldwin New York at panic attacks so
agoraphobia and how I got through those
was just step by step
one stop off a subway one stop off the
LIRR one stop off a you know and that's
what it takes I rapid movement I mean if
you yeah if you suffer for there's
there's many things out that you just
have to explore but like for me except
the xanax usually in the Valium I'm off
all that [ __ ] I don't do I don't do any
xanax I don't do any pain pills I was
doing it I had to take xanax to sleep I
had to take this and I go what are you
doing man I don't want to live like this
for the rest of my [ __ ] life it's
really messing me up it really it's a
and you realized you are addicted even
though I wasn't taking tons of pills I
was addicted I was I was addicted to it
and I wanted to take a Norco at 2:00 in
the afternoon just to have a couple
hours of relief I got it I was looking
for any [ __ ] relief I could get and
you know what I do now I try to once a
week I'm like man I have emotions inside
of me like I've been Tucker my grandma
she's alone and she said she's sad it
makes me all these things with family in
my I'll just go downstairs by myself at
night no one's here cuz I'm alone I'm
single and I will I go what's a movie
that what's a scene from a movie that
you know gets you and I'll watch the
scene from whatever the [ __ ] whether
it's a cheesy movie that gets me every
time even if it's five minutes I won't
dwell on it I won't keep watching that
scene over and over and I will [ __ ]
cry I will get some [ __ ] out of my
system and it feels so [ __ ] good and
I'll go up and I'll sleep and I just
want to [ __ ] take a few minutes to
just feel to feel to be real to be like
I'm feeling this this is these are
emotions this is something I just I I
don't know what it is but when I when I
went to that place and I start crying
like you said talk about safe places I
felt safe first time I live I felt safe
I told him that and that's why crying
was like I I always felt like I was a
puss if I was crying I don't cry in
front of my friends and the next thing
you know I'm crying she was are you okay
we could stop it oh no this is [ __ ]
great I it feels good I want to [ __ ]
cry this is you know
it was wrong mobility yeah it sounds
like that's a tough thing for you and
myself myself I know for sure you don't
cry in front of people a lot do you I
know well no do you cry in front of like
guys you date have I yeah is it hard for
you no I don't think the crying part is
hard what's the hard part I think is
allowing yourself to get to that place
that you can be instead of making
decision to leave making a decision to
stay and work through something means
that you got to get vulnerable you know
it's funny they say that about anxiety
they say if you're having an anxiety
attack
don't leave the scene of the crime stay
there stay in it [ __ ] feel it and
otherwise you run every time you go back
to a situation like that you'll run
you'll phobic
that's what phobias really are you
become a scared like a dog if a dog
attacks you with its dogs dogs next
thing you know you hear a dog bark and
you're you're that anxiety it's somatic
it'll happen goes in your body did you
think we were gonna talk about getting
so deep today I don't know baby
I mean honestly you look a little bit
maybe like wow I thought we're gonna
talk more about my career and all this
stuff but let me talk about your life I
love it I'm good I like it
I love this that's the summer doing this
crap you can't what do mean you spent a
summer um
this summer I had a couple of health
things when you when you start getting a
couple of health things and one of them
had to do with my voice so haul ups I
did and what does that mean when you get
a polyp uh well when you sing like I do
it means that you have developed a I
burst some capillaries on my vocal cords
from overworking and doing and doing and
at my age I guess I didn't recover as
well like an athlete I didn't recover so
I had to get surgery to get them removed
so that was a month of not talking six
weeks and not singing speaking
everything and then retraining and it
was scary and it was a lot and it was a
juggle so I had to go inside and figure
out what was going on and it was the
quiet was unbelievable and I went to a
couple of places that really supported
that and one of them similar to what you
did not a wellness however you want to
call it and one of them was the Hoffman
process I did the Hoffman Institute
and that was deep work that was in
August but deep is where you got to go
sometime expensive no not really
probably cheaper than the one I went to
I don't know what you did baby you're
our sponsors please keep signing up no
it was worth it um yeah it's worth it
well I'm glad you're doing well you know
by the way this is the best I've seen
you look you serious I swear to god
that's that's the truth I'm not I'd
promised to god I wouldn't have said
that when you walked up I was like [ __ ]
you look great
not that you never look great you just
look better yeah amen you know people a
lot of women are guys they get upset
when people said that oh you look really
good no I'm like wait a minute what do
you mean as opposed to last month you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I mean but
it's true it's like my dad send the
phone he's like you look thin like well
I'm on a nutritional thing I'm working
I'm trying to get better shave easily
you look too thin I hate being too thin
no did it's just the same if you call a
guy thin it's the same thing it's good
having a girl call a girl fat yeah yeah
I guess so
girls wouldn't think of it that way but
it's true but no I hear you I hear yeah
yeah yeah
I don't means you not cut means you're
not fit but your father doesn't get it
then you're a lean machine I'm Alisha
you know I wanted you see now after you
talked about your polyps mm-hmm I don't
like the name polyps I wish they'd
changed no honey Jackson the polyps
maybe Jackson polyp it's really nasty
just like growths on your eye burst I
sang on a heavy duty fever and stuff
like that and I burst capillaries and
what happens is it's like uh what is
this like a when you get what whatever
you call it like that when you're
lifting weights and you get these things
all what they call callus a callus but
the thing is a polyp is a bump so you
keep singing on it you don't rest it and
it can continue to grow scar tissue all
over it and that's what happens and
that's what happened because I didn't
stop the jam
but Rosie picks up a guitar Ryan how
much how much input do you have on this
stuff I don't know but he weighs about
to do how slow what is it yeah okay
I feel the night explode when we're
together there you go emotional below in
the heat of measure will save me I'm
yours
into your arms never let me go tonight I
really need to know
[Applause]
Janice in my heart tell me I'm the only
one it's just really lover Dustin gay
turn through my heart I can feel my body
rock every time you call my name
there you go [ __ ] on yes do you that you
can just sing like that you see how we
need another better song all right Rosie
what do you want to sing girl oh my god
I love the kissed off I know Jim Croce I
know
Hall and Oates
[Music]
remember this what is this opera I know
it's kind of a waking Lotus goddess aka
I hope you understand every time I try
to tell you the words just came out
wrong so I have to say I love you in a
song dude dude dude it's a good one
Cat Stevens
Oh took my love took it down so you
could sing anyway what's your favorite
music to sing no favorite music just a
song that's inspired me
what's your who's your favorite artist
ooh Aretha Franklin no I mean Aretha was
totally incredible but I have to say
Joni Mitchell it's not just an artist
like anything from blue anything from
ladies of the canyon that was just
profound stuff for me that was that it's
a 15 year old 16 year old girl and just
it was just
KCU right mm-hmm Gladys Knight
Gladys midnight train to Georgia could
be my favorites one of my favorite songs
of all time
I just sang something at her 75th
birthday and it wasn't midnight train to
Georgia of course she did but I did cuz
you're the best thing that ever happened
to me I think so
something that has some relevance to
emotional like angst against something
that's a happy chord like Gap Band like
Charlie Wilson when you drop the bomb um
so like a funky verse right yeah Bruno
Mars is nailed that has to Mars is
pretty incredible I don't like a lot of
modern music but yeah oh he's incredible
I mean animal did you listen to Michael
McDonald like everything and I told and
I've sang with Michael
alright let's pretend I'm Michael
McDonald okay so Michael Michael is the
most humble of me and I go Michael just
do me this favorite soundcheck I
remember saying to Michael could you
play the intro for a minute-by-minute
for me like just play it so I can like
like just sit here and like die and he'd
be like yeah but he would just do it on
that it's that heart hammond a little
Richie you you played with him played
with Lionel no we never sang together no
no put your favorite Lionel song oh
mylanta okay so it would be Commodore
stuff what was it once easy like Sunday
morning I don't know I don't know how
that song it's not gonna be hello cuz
all I can see is a blind girl making a
bust
[Applause]
nor sounds funny but I just can't stand
a plane even news we have seems to me
girl you know I done all I can
[Music]
yeah your big stone I borrow yeah you
gotta get that fading coat yeah
that's why I'm easy there you go
you get this one firm easy like Sunday
more
[Music]
I didn't know we were going to that part
this has been awesome oh my god love you
baby I love this did your fun oh yes
hundred baby I love this we're gonna
hang out you live over the hill I live
five minutes from I always keep thinking
cuz you're so New York you know you live
in New York are you playing a lot still
yeah I mean I know you are but you
playing around here anymore
keep it play at the Agora Hells Canyon
Club tell people where you are so then
go see you now
just go on my website Taylor Dayne calm
or anything on Instagram tailored the
real Taylor Dayne yeah you're the real
dude tweet her Instagram her go see he
will [ __ ] yourself when you see it a lot
you give it all your musics amazing
thank you and you got so much hearts and
it's nice to see the the human insight
you know people always think of us you
know you're a musician all her songs but
like when you really we did today was
it's been it's my 30 year anniversary
last year so it really reflection is
part of the key of being grateful right
an appreciation and and all the work you
do on your inside is what reflects on
the outside so I'm ever grateful and I
ever appreciate you and we've had a nice
friendship it's great I'm grateful all
right thanks for allowing me to be
inside you thanks for listening what a
great story and very powerful it's
powerful how you could just she just
tells it how it is and she is she strong
and she still sounds great in concert
man she still plays her ass off you know
what I mean I mean she's kind of great
in his room didn't she
oh my god she could just like she
doesn't care if she did she's one of
those musicians who I needed like hey
can you put some reverb on there we edit
that but not with these music but these
guys have been doing it their whole
lives
I Taylor is just a sensational talent
thank you for listening again by the way
if you like that spread the word one
more week next week we've got a great
ending to the just the audio podcasts
it's really a good one next one is a
great one to end on but don't worry
because the week after yours your buddy
right here Ryan is editing the first
episode which will be on YouTube and all
over Spotify in the same platforms you
can list
to it so nothing changes for you but I
will ask you to do me a favor go to
youtube and look inside of you of micro
zone and subscribe subscribe press the
subscribe button and then you could
watch it you could listen to it you know
maybe both that would be really helpful
I want to shout out to the top tier
patrons who have really helped us out
gave us the ability to buy some cameras
here so we could film this thing in a
few weeks and here they are
Allison L Andrew see Angelina G Barry L
Bob be bautex Chris Dion k we got Emily
Emily s mah Jason D Jason W Jerry W Jill
E Kevin R Kristin K wonder if that's
Kristin Kreuk Lauren G Lee s a lovely
highly and Lauren mark a Matthew J
Michael s Nancy hi Nancy D Nico P ROG
Robert L Sarah V Scott be Sean W Tiana
Trisha
Yukiko I love my little Yukiko and also
my my assistant Jess you know she's a
patron know and I think that's really
sweet so I want to give you a shout out
Jess she won't ever listen to the outro
you know we get letters a lot and it
really has surprised me in the last few
months
Ryan it's it's pretty cool because I
didn't get I used to get some letters
but now in the last six months or so
it's like every day we get letters and
so I'd like to of course read you this
one hey Rosie my wife and I are huge
fans of Smallville and came across your
podcast this last june after listening
to the first couple I was immediately
hooked I listened to every episode in
order until I finally cut up your most
recent episodes around October and have
been up to date since this also includes
all of the in love episodes which is no
longer Ryan but it was a good time thank
you I love the openness of them and
really getting to know you and all of
the guests as with many of the other
listeners and guests I have had my share
of issues and love hearing how others
have coped and learning something from
every episode I've also shared many of
the ideas expressed such as being
present with my kids and team
work each week I look forward to the new
episode every Tuesday and listen to it
first thing on my way to to and from
work I have to say the newest episodes
this year have been top-notch and I'm
excited to see where it goes from here
good luck keep up the good work you're
doing great things with this show
forever your fan David n from Fort Worth
Texas David it makes me feel really good
and you know I'm trying to get better
you know people say ask me if I listen
to the show I don't really listen once I
interview someone I just don't really
like listening to myself because I know
I'll just tear myself apart Oh cut that
do that with the videos that Ryan's
gonna start editing I'll probably look
at the fat least the beginning to see if
we're on the right track to see what
were you know and so far they look great
Ryan so thank you for making me look
giving it a thumbs up less of an [ __ ]
but thank you for that I do it is let's
see here
this is from Kyle oh well this is from
Steven do you Michael I wrote a review
about it side of you I just wanted you
to know how much this podcast means to
me there's been a lot that's happened in
my life and your pot has helped me come
to terms with a lot of it I was in an
abusive relationship back in 2012 and
because of it I became broken I thought
that I was broken beyond repair for
seven years I struggle with mental
illness but I didn't even know I had
after a suicide attempt in August 2009
teen I discovered I had auditory
schizophrenia I already knew I suffered
from depression and anxiety which was
just made worse by the abuse I went
through I found your podcast in late
2019 and I've been listening to every
episode since I can't express how much
it means to me and how much your care
for others means to me thank you once
again I hope you keep doing inside of
you for a long time I wish you all the
best well Steven that means a lot and
you know obviously I'm not a doctor I've
said this a million times
although Jeff seems to think she calls
me dr. Rosenbaum because the doctor will
say one thing to me I'll go you know I'm
not gonna do that oh oh really dr.
Rosenbaum oh really but what I'm trying
to say is you know I don't know a lot
about when I say mental illness I know
that we all have anxieties and all these
things and obviously auditory
schizophrenia is something I know
nothing about and
hoping that your uh you're talking to
people who do know about that and have
studied their whole lives to become the
doctors that they are and I just love
hearing that you know my podcast has
done something to help you to make you
uh if nothing else it just seems like
it's it's relatable we can all sort of
say hey I get that I understand that I
hear that it's not all just fluffy and
fun sometimes I'm sometimes it's fluffy
and fun but you know that's the whole
point the point is to just you know one
guest says one thing in an hour that
you're like really resonated and
sometimes there's more but I think
that's that's what I try to capture
because I need it
it's like advice when I'm talking to
someone and they say something profound
I'm like oh my god I'm gonna use that
thank you so much I forget sometimes
that I'm even on a podcast that you know
other people are listening but then I
realize oh wow I think that's cool maybe
some of them do too so anyway Thank You
Steven for that wonderful wonderful note
thank you to everyone but remember the
handles at inside you pod
I think it's on Instagram it's inside
you podcast or inside a pod on Twitter
or vice versa and make sure you join us
follow us spread the word remember I'll
be in Richmond on the 28th 29th doing a
small the Knights and then a stage it on
Sunday anything coming up for you Ryan
no well I have nothing to promote but
you can go to your youtube video yeah
you could say I'm still popping up on
the warp zone YouTube channel every now
and again and that's stuff that's all
there check him out cuz you're gonna
become a fan then you could follow me
what's your handle at taya's ryan at tay
as its te ll easy i think that's easy
isn't it yeah easy easy ryan thanks so
much for listening and remember the left
on Laurel you can get the album
everywhere it's free online and all that
stuff in the merch store for inside of
you and left and laurels at the inside
of you store online I think that's about
it that I cover at all I think I did
yeah all right much love to everybody
and by the way we are gonna do a live
podcast it looks like right now unless
things get canceled but who's around in
late March or early April for a podcast
in Austin Texas a live podcast who would
come I want you to tweet me and say
Rosenbaum
absolutely would come to Austin for the
live podcast I just like to get a maybe
a head count
maybe if I see a hundred people then
we're gonna do it but we're working on
it I want to do a live podcast I've
always wanted to do it so tell me what
you think of that idea I love you thanks
so much thank you for loud to be inside
each and every one of you
[Music]